whip reject nation only like a month and
a half or a little bit more than that
until spider-man no way home comes out
so you best be on the lookout for so
much coming in spider-man no way home
green goblin mcguire and garfield
costume scorpion and plot leaks guys
i've been hearing so much about trailer
2 all right i'm going to give you guys
my personal update and talking with a
couple of sources you know how sometimes
we're on top of stuff it's because i
have one or two sources i know i was
saying earlier that's probably going to
come after eternals the the week and
then but i actually
think trailer number two is probably
most likely going to come the week when
ghostbusters comes out which makes the
most sense to me now because that is a
sony pitchers production you want to get
more people in the theaters probably go
check out that trailer especially if
toby maguire and andrew garfield are
there whoever's watching ghostbusters
will see that trailer and be like i
gotta go watch this in the theaters
either way it's coming out this month
i'd be very surprised trailer number two
came out december it's coming out this
month 14.
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and i hope you're ready
for a heavy halloween as we have a ton
of new looks and plot details for
spider-man no way home yesterday the
internet was hit up with a lot of leaks
that even jay jonah jameson would have
been proud of and we have some first
looks at the green goblin costume
confirmation of what toby maguire and
andrew garfield will be wearing some
plot leaks some plot leaks debunked and
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you're one of the three people that
haven't had the movie ruined by the
internet then you better get out of here
at breakneck speed like gwen stacy
[Music]
the costumes we're about to talk about
floating around in dms i was too busy
chatting to hop babes online all day to
see them and that's what i'm telling
marvel if kevin foggy comes in knocking
in addition to me definitely not seeing
them descriptions of the suits were
posted on subreddit marvel studios
spoilers we heard about the descriptions
said that they'd sent in the images to
the subreddit but as they hadn't been
given credit they wanted to make him
regret it so decided to post them all
over the internet
youtube is a place where you can dmca
someone in a second and have their whole
channel removed if you want to without
even asking for rent so i'm not going to
be able to show all of the images in
this video but they are out there if you
want to look however what we do have is
something
knocked up
and i think that should be fine to go
over as it's not being created by sony
now the first thing i want to talk about
is the three spiderman suits
and toby mcguire would be reprising
their versions of peter parker in the
movie but we didn't know whether this
would be in brand new costumes or not
however we can confirm that toby will be
wearing his suit from the raimi trilogy
with garfield wearing his one from the
amazing spider-man 2. damn is that those
are the actual costumes there that's
what it looks like yeah oh it's a snap
that's a shot of wardrobe straight out
of the actual move oh my god that's
insane it's exactly what was described
the owner of this phone has been
murdered surely by now
yeah yeah dude exactly as described god
it's all it's all three suits
it's crazy i love this so much i love
this so much it's all right there hell
yeah that's what i like to see now one
costume that has changed up slightly is
the green goblin outfit as i said we
will be using fan mock-ups but they're
pretty much what was shown in the images
the costume is highly battle damaged and
it also comes with belts and pouches
that are full of the goblins tricks and
weapons first thing you're probably
gonna notice is that the green goblin
doesn't have a mask and instead he has
some goggles that look a lot like doctor
octopuses from spider-man 2. i have seen
a lot of people saying that they're
gonna add the mask but from what i've
heard this is how the goblin is gonna
look now why that is is because the
movie is basically gonna be pulling the
villains out of the multiverse the
second before they died as the goblin
wasn't masked and in a battle damaged
costume this is the version that's going
to be brought into the mcu you can even
see that the goblin costume looks very
similar to how it was when he got
stabbed at the dick
guys going to be pulled across just
after he got stabbed in the dekyo now
from what i've heard when he comes into
the mcu he will take octopuses goggles
and then wear them a big criticism that
people had for the raimi costume was
that you basically paid for willem dafoe
who has a very iconic face and then
covered it up with a big green power
rangers helmet marvel is wanting to lean
into defoe's most notable features and
this is why this time around he won't be
wearing the mask all these years i've
never even had that thought of like why
would you cover up he's the green goblin
he has a mask yeah green goblin's
usually has a mask usually he could have
a mask too that allows his face to move
for sure i don't know it never bothered
me no and i mean from my experience
watching it growing up i could always
see his mouth and eyes underneath it so
like willem defoe's rack of teeth and
all that was still a part of the
character to me so i feel like i still
got some of his unique traits coming
through the mask but yeah i was never
bothered by it especially within the
context of the story you're not supposed
to know it's norman osborne or the
public's not supposed to know it's
norman osborne yeah if he's just out
there
if he painted himself green or something
it's still like oh is that you but i do
like the idea of pulling him straight
out here it makes it feel a little bit
more personal like this is a real
vendetta for him where that personal
like i need to you know fight spider-man
didn't come until way late into the
movie if you're going to kick off like
thrusting willem dafoe into this
automatically lends some type of
subconscious personal association to the
fact that he's just letting himself be
exposed now i think the costume looks
absolutely incredible and aaron s bailey
did a brilliant markup of the leaked
scene we'd heard about when goblin goes
to the villains that have been captured
in stranger sanctorum prison going
beyond that from what i've heard on the
film osborne will land in the mcu and
he'll be sort of torn between his two
personalities he will then wear a
blanket in order to make himself look
homeless and he'll go to aunt may's
feast operations like in the fire
oh
okay
and this will be where he tries to
convince him to free them ah
actually all this complex you've heard
have we heard that yeah i don't think so
there's not not norman osborn showing up
at fees that's a smart way to do it and
i think that's actually really great too
they'll be bringing over the fact that
he has the conflicting personalities
within himself that's actually a trait
that i sometimes forget about when
flashing to that movie because of the
movies finale and how it all ends it's
just a much more fascinating dichotomy
for what he has to go through when this
character is already thrusted into this
like larger than life multiverse
scenario perhaps it could lend itself to
this opportunity of uh
maybe this could be a chance for a
second opportunity or maybe this could
be a chance for a second opportunity to
dominate
you know which personality will
ultimately yeah i hope we get a good
mirror scene for those men oh you better
bring the bear scenes back now if you've
been watching our other plot league
videos then you'll know we've talked
about a big death in the film i'm not
going to drop that here as i think it is
quite a big spoiler and i have to give
another spoiler warning which i really
can't be bothered with however
apparently the scene of the building on
fire from the trailer is this moment and
after peter attempts to stop goblin he
goes to this person's house and blows it
up with them inside it's pretty shocking
and it mirrors a big thing that also
happened in the ring right
[Music]
oh
just got pieced together
all right guys you better click off the
video because i'm going to talk about
what paul doesn't want to talk about
we already heard about it in a video
last week yeah a big rumor circulating
is that aunt may is going to die when
you think about spider-man 1 when he
attacks rosemary harris you know when
she's like praying and then the devil
shows up that would be a cool scene that
reflects that except he actually goes
through with that and actually kills her
wow that would be oh my god yeah let's
talk about like your different timeline
threads and you're like uh rhyming it
almost reminds me of what uh is that
george lucas talking about like rhyming
plot themes and stuff like that that
especially in rhymes like yeah
you you couldn't
you weren't 100 confident poetry oh it
doesn't have to rhyme all right just go
always have to write
was it george lucas who taught
really did george lucas
making it like poetry
you know i just gotta be sure we're
mixing fandoms today
star wars now we're in spiderman i gotta
make sure that would be super awesome
except it would be also heartbreaking i
feel like if they killed her off they
find a way to bring her back oh yeah
it was debunked that the rhino will be
in the movie this is something that we
reported on for a while and then i heard
the opposite to it and started putting
my theories out for who the final
sinister six film would be but everyone
called me a [ __ ] because as we all knew
it was definitely rhino
i kind of feel like i should have just
went with my gut and said what i thought
instead of being like well all these
people must be the ones who are right
and i feel like i'm gonna have to make
another i was wrong video because
apparently he's not in the movie
throughout the week we got a lot of new
clips that were labeled as being leaks
from the second trailer but they've now
been debunked as being alternate takes
that come from the first one this
included a scene in which peter had just
stopped a criminal and he then had green
paint thrown over his suit shouts to
cosmic wonder who earlier in the week
released this scoop and he said that
this is how peter actually ends up
getting his black costume the scene
actually starred tom holland's brother
as the bank robber and then peter strung
him up which is when he had the paint
thrown over him he can't wash this out
and he ends up turning the suit inside
out which is how he gets the black one
which is basically just the red and
black one reversed there was also mum
which spider-man swung through the city
and he was grabbed by dr strange's cloak
with it sitting around his shoulders
like how it was and what if this then
pulled him back and apparently leads
into the moment from the first look in
which strange then knocks peter out of
his body so that he can take the cube
back there were also some alternate
takes of things like strange chasing
peter through new york and a couple of
additional shots of the ladder being
thrown against the wall however we have
to stress that this is not the second
trailer and it's just alternate scenes
from the first one that ultimately
didn't end up getting used i saw that
footage that was going around online you
would never react to the only to feel
like a leak trailer a lot of footage
going around and yeah you can't be
fooled into thinking that's the second
trailer that is clearly a alternate
first take it's like a few seconds that
are different you know disappointing of
a second trailer that would be ooh we
got a couple of new shots this shot went
on two seconds longer crazy but the
structure and beats of it are very it's
pretty much the same thing just a couple
of moments were swiped out with
something else still just like where do
you where do you get access to that yeah
i know right as for the trailer itself i
don't think it's gonna come until at
least the middle of november at the
earliest anyway i'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you drop them
below and let me know i think you did a
great job paul i'm happy we're best
friends
i i don't know why you don't let me call
you my best friend oh i tried he got
worn very jealous
john could care less but i've been
trying to coin you as my best friend you
keep calling me an acquaintance you guys
can subscribe to john's youtube channel
john and the humphreys
check it out it's him and his family
performing songs from the 50s
it's a
great man john's on base maybe start it
actually doing that
sounds startling see you guys